[Music]
the current president is the first
person to jump straight from television
to the presidency he may not be the last
we learned that last night during the
Golden Globes there was a heavy focus on
sexual assault and harassment hundreds
of actors quietly enabled that behavior
for years of course but last night they
collectively vowed to stop it
the biggest star though was Oprah
Winfrey Harvey Weinstein's old friend
who won a standing ovation with this I
want all the girls watching here now to
know that a new day is on the horizon
and win that new day finally Dawn's
it will be because of a lot of
magnificent women to make sure that they
become the leaders who take us to the
time when nobody ever has to say me to
again boy if you didn't weep as hard as
Tom Hanks did you're just not human the
speech didn't just win Oprah applause
many people predictably are talking
about Oprah running for president this
morning because there are 24 hours to
fill on cable news that speculation was
fueled by reports on Monday that Oprah
is seriously considering a run Jennifer
Rubin who poses a conservative over at
the Washington Post tweeted Oprah Yates
2020 sad old Bill Kristol the former
editor of The Weekly Standard tweeted
hashtag I'm with her so all the kids are
saying that MSNBC how was joy read
suggested Oprah's already the president
least in spirit quote switched back to
the Golden Globes to watch Oprah get her
award never let it be said that I don't
respect the president United States
would be a spiritual president of course
when you see if I was a college
professor and she joins us tonight when
it's good to see it thank you for having
me
so I'm actually just a moment of
seriousness now
Oprah is very talented as a community
which was one of the great communicators
actually and obviously if she ran in the
Democratic primary she'd win that's all
daytime TV viewers from voting in that
primary and she would win how would you
feel if you were senator gillibrand or
one of the people who spent years kind
of preparing for this planning to run in
the primary getting blown out by Oprah I
guess I'll feel the same way that Marco
Rubio or Jeb Bush felt or Ted Cruz felt
when Trump blew them out this is not
something for us to look at in a vacuum
so to speak Oprah Winfrey is very
talented she brings people together
she's not divisive she makes you feel
warm inside and right now our country is
very divided and what she did last night
was she healed us she brought us all
together and that is what is needed hard
wait hold on how did she heal us she
healed us because she spoke to issues
that a lot of people are facing whether
you're a woman she was intertwined
racial division she mentioned that in
there she talked about you know not just
women coming together but women and men
coming together that's what we need in
the leader I'm gonna men come together
kind of naturally absolutely biological
reasons for you know Wow absolutely but
what we have seen is with the me2
movement there has been women who have
been standing up saying what is
happening to us whether we are working
in Hollywood or whether we're working in
politics is not good but we need to have
men who are also saying the same thing
and I made sure to call to arms to say
everyone needs to come together so it
was bothered by the pictures of her
kissing Harvey Weinstein or anything
like that that didn't seem a little
weird it's not that it's weird there's
lots of people who were kissing Harvey
Weinstein right and even though I mean
and even though most resident right now
has been accused of sexual harassment
but it's one thing to go from kissing
Harvey Weinstein to being the face of me
- shouldn't there be an intermediate
step where you say sorry I kissed Harvey
Weinstein great point let's talk about
the intermediate step the intermediate
step is that in 1990 Oprah actually
passed a bill in which made sure that
people who abuse children were
registered we passed a bill no it's
named after her is called the Oprah bill
is the National Child Protection Act in
1990 so she has a history of doing being
in the Congress in passing no she has a
he has a history of moving things
forward by using her platform and that's
what we need we need a leader who uses
their platform to do things that are
positive that's what Donald Trump does
not do and that's what Oprah has done
for countless years and in 1990 Donald
Trump even said if he had a VP it would
be Oprah Winfrey for sure so I wonder
though if it's do you know being a
universally beloved daytime talk show
host and talking about you know whatever
she talked about he's a little different
from being a politician right wouldn't
she become slightly less beloved maybe
something more divisive if she were to
weigh in on some of the thorny issues of
the day maybe she could I mean look at
Donald Trump he has become more divisive
but the differences but the difference
is that were Oprah Winfrey she stuck to
the script she stuck to healing she
stuck to making sure our nation is
coming together she did not say one side
is better than the other and what's
really important
here with Oprah Winfrey and that we need
the kid telling thing that's totally
real you felt you he didn't he didn't
have a tearjerker moment what you always
do when I watch did it give you any
pause that like Bill Kristol yes took
time out from advocating for a know Ron
invasion to and to support Oprah do you
think maybe this is a little this is not
the Oprah I know the one who gets
support from Bill Kristol no it's not
that I for me I felt that 2018 is off to
a good start where we saw someone who
was rallying at the country in a
positive way and whether that's Oprah
Winfrey and Bill Christie decides to
jump on that bandwagon that's all great
it's good that we're coming today wonder
if maybe because you're not really
describing a politician you're
describing just figure she heals people
she passes legislation without even
being in Congress now she brings men and
women together
I mean uses a platform for good that is
what a leader does is snarky remarks but
I'm gonna we can criticize her but we
have to give her her kudos and that is
she uses her platform effectively I'm
gonna need to go to confession if you
even think an unkind thought about Oprah
Winfrey at this point we use your last
name yes okay Wendy thank you you're
welcome thank you